My thyroid test results indicate poor T4 conversion, but my antibodies are okay. Any ideas?
Could my intermittent fasting be driving T4 to reverse T3? Okay, so here's the tests.
We'll get to this question here in a second. TSH is barely in range.
Media is actually low. 3T4 is high in the range. Reverse T3 is out of range. So
if you looked at the autoimmune course and there's a whole section in the autoimmune course
on thyroid. So make sure you go and spend a little bit of time on that. But your thyroid
secretes thyroid hormone. Mainly, 97% is in T4. 5 to 10% is in the active form of T3.
And then T4 is converted to T3 in the gut end of the liver. And this person is asking,
why is my T4 getting converted to reverse T3? If your T4 gets converted to reverse T3,
then that reverse T3 is inactive and you can never become in active again. So it's become useless.
That's called conversion defect here. You have an under conversion. So T4 is converting
to reverse T3 instead of active T3. And that's an issue. That could be a problem. Well,
that's a gut issue and a liver issue. Is the possibility that question is, could my intermittent
fasting be driving T4 to T3 to reverse T3? I don't know. I've never seen any literature on that.
I've never, I have not seen any studies on that. I don't think they exist. So I'm not sure about that.
Your TPO and thyroid globulent antibodies are normal. That's good. That means you don't have
Hashimoto's. So that's great. But your three T3 is barely in range on the low side because you have
that T4 conversion. So what do you do about this? This may be the same person that asked this question
about the gut. Now, this may be a reason to do a gut test because you could have parasites that could
be causing that. It's a possibility that Hpylori could cause that. That's just my suspect.
And that's the case. Got parasite test will test for Hpylori. But you could rule out parasites by
doing a gut test. Copper is out of range and low at 78. That goes to what does low copper indicate to
you. Well, if you didn't have cancer, you'd maybe want to supplement a little bit of copper. But
somebody that has cancer, you'd like to keep a low copper level. So with the cancer diagnosis, I'd say
you, you just keep a low copper level. That's a good thing. But with the rest of this question,
you may want to investigate if you have parasites that's causing that conversion issue.
Personally, I would just start taking some murmuring because that will help kill any Hpylori that
can help kill some parasites. I'd spend my money on just taking a few supplements, maybe by a
model of our pair of clear or something like that, or just get some murmuring and use some
burberry to help kill Hpylori. And then maybe retest the symptom. Sure, you're clever. Retesting,